you so now moving on to each candidate's
individual question we are keeping the
same order so um mr nora gets the first
question here tonight uh you have been
successful as a venture capitalist and
you've been a
successful business background as well
you have said that that business
background will help you govern the
state however you would certainly need
the support of a very likely democratic
legislature so you have a 60 seconds
here to answer since you have no
government experience how would you get
anything done if elected as governor
so uh first and foremost
uh when you've been a venture capitalist
like i have
if you think that the legislature is a
problem try working with other venture
capitalists okay they're the smartest
people in the room
and usually they are
and they know everything better than
everybody else and that was just in my
partnership
now think about the investments i was
involved in outside of my partnership
where we had boards of directors
consisting of seven or eight to nine
people
so
i think dealing with the actual people
in in carson city
is going to be
easy for me having dealt what i've dealt
with before and it takes an outsider
so i'm not going to come in with the
biases even the bias that you just say
well yeah it's going to be hard to work
with these people it's a total opposite
i come in with nothing to lose and a lot
to gain for the people in nevada i'm
working for them i'm not working the
system i'm not a politician i'm just
trying to solve problems for the people
in nevada and that's what i'm going to
be doing and that's how i will do it
mr nora thank you vanessa has our next
individual question
thank you this next question is for mr
lombardo kevin mcmahill is running for
clark county sheriff the position you
currently hold he was your second in
command at the department before he
retired and you've endorsed him to
replace you as sheriff in 1995 when
kevin mcmahill was a metro police
officer
a fellow metro officer says she
witnessed mcmahill and his partner
commit misconduct during a stop
following the incident mcmahill failed a
polygraph
we're going to play part of an eight
news now i-team report they made me come
over by their car and lift my skirt and
show my privates
and then they took me to the front of
the car
and they went through my purse and they
found a small amount of
crack cocaine
and they said if i wanted to go
that i would have to eat that did you
ever ask a woman
while you were working as an officer to
see her genitals never i'm an irish guy
i wear my my emotion on my sleeve i was
huffing and puffing and i was very upset
before i ever got hooked up to that box
no chance in hell that i ever passed
that test
mr lombardo you have 60 seconds to
answer do you believe kevin mcmahill's
two female accusers
well all i know is that
one particular i don't know anything
about the other female accuser the one
female accuser has been
impeached
for lack of integrity in another case
that i've become aware of and quite
often i got asked a question first of
all i think this is a ridiculous
question it has nothing to do with
running this for the state of nevada for
the governor's position
and
but i will opine on it and i will to
discuss it because you're questioning my
ability to endorse this individual i
believe that's the direction you're
going with this and i support kevin
mcmahon 100
this is an incident that took place 25
years ago and he went through the due
process associated with that and he was
cleared associated with those crimes he
had worked for three previous sheriffs
prior to me before rising up into the
ranks and then i eventually made a
decision to make undersheriff and he did
a fantastic job during his tenure as the
underserved
mr lombardo thank you you mentioned she
was impeached have you seen
documentation to show that in 30 seconds
yes i have
okay thank you denise has the next
question moving on now to mr gilbert you
have called to reopen the investigation
into the one october shooting saying on
your facebook page cover-up where's the
money who was in that room mr gilbert
you have 60 seconds to answer what do
you think about the one october shooting
was covered up
it's very simple you know i spent a lot
of time first of all i lived in las
vegas from 2003 until 2008 i opened a
business down here 2013-16
a lot of friends down here and every
time i'm down here someone brings up the
route 91 shooting on whether it's the
money or whether it's finding out who
was who was all in that room they don't
believe that the investigation was done
properly i've even met with metro
officers and they've all said that at
the end of the day that there's just you
know the the it has there hasn't been
full transparency on what took place
there's timelines that are off there's
you know things that are you know we
look at witness statements you look at
video and again i've i've dug in as much
as i can i do not have the knowledge
that you know others do so as i've said
you know and i've said this numerous
times i reserve that from once i'm in as
governor and i can take a look at it at
the end of the day i'm not going to call
anybody's integrity into question but
i'll just say that it's been told to me
numerous times that there was not
necessarily a cover-up but people
haven't been forthright there's not
enough transparency and i said as
governor to get to the bottom of it i
think nevadans are due and answer five
years later if there's still questions
so uh mr lombardi were
cleared out they're talking about the
fact that he doesn't feel there was
transparency he has questions about this
investigation mr lombardo let me give
you a moment to reply to that
yeah thank you for the opportunity well
i was directly
involved in that incident as you can
imagine and i lived it for several years
even today
and for people to
pune my officer's integrity and the
investigation associated with that is
ridiculous and i i stand by them in all
aspects of that investigation and to
include the allegations that i embezzled
along with
mr sisilak 30 million dollars associated
that with that for the victims
we have posted on my website the
distribution of that money to disprove
those allegations every day i'm
presented with individuals based with
joey gilbert's campaign accusing me of
an improper investigation a cover-up a
conspiracy and
embezzling the 30 million dollars we
have posted the full investigation
different than any police department
entire nation in this aspect involving a
mass shooting the full investigation is
posted on the lvmpd website in full
color for people to fully review mr
lombardo thank you for that steve
mr heller this next question is for you
back in 2006 you told the review journal
that you were pro-choice in january of
this year you said you were pro-life in
2017 you said at a town hall that you'd
protect planned parenthood and had no
problem with federal funding for it the
next day your campaign clarified that
you opposed funding for planned
parenthood so mr heller the question is
this and you have 60 seconds to reply
how can voters trust that the positions
you're taking today will be the same
positions you take if you're elected
well first of all i am pro-life and i'm
proud of it let's get that clear and uh
some of those uh questions or concerns
that you brought up uh uh i was probably
more libertarian at the time when i when
when i
kind of kept a hands-off situation here
when it came to the abortion question
when i got to congress i had to make a
decision and i have an a plus rating
with the nevada right to life and the
national right to life i have always
voted uh uh consistently in the in in
that
manner having said that uh the planned
parenthood comment yes i have to admit
that i i misspoke i was talking about
mammograms and women's health not
funding for planned parenthood i have
my record is very very clear 100 percent
having voted against any funding for
planned parenthood my record will
continue uh when i am governor of this
state to be pro-life i am proud of the
fact that we have two supreme court
justices back in washington d.c that are
going to overturn roe v wade kavanaugh
and gorsuch and i voted for both of them
to bring this issue back to the state of
nevada because it's time for us to have
a discussion here in the state of nevada
and where we want to go on this
particular issue thank you mr heller
vanessa
thank you the next question is for mr
lee on april 10th a firearms instructor
made racist comments at a training event
for concealed weapons permits you were
sitting in the front row at the time
let's take a look at a brief clip
always on your fingers
always
mr lee you have 60 seconds you are the
only republican running for office in
attendance that hasn't publicly
commented on that presentation here's
your opportunity tonight yeah so i was
sitting there and that was like 10 12
seconds whatever it was and i was on the
print work because i want to learn as
much as i could this was an opportunity
for me to understand the ccw laws and he
made those stupid statements and after
the event i went up and said you should
never do that if you want to be a
successful businessman you need to learn
how to curb your mouth you need to learn
how to curb your presentation
now when people started calling me it's
not my job to try to run him out of
business it's not my job to to to follow
the press and and follow along and do
what they want me to say and do i had a
private conversation with him but why
was i getting a ccw that was the thing i
was there because
north las vegas we used to be number one
in crime we're not anymore i put 10 more
million dollars in the budget we have
200 more police officers we open our
jail and so right now we're number four
in crime we've got metro joe lombardo
sparks reno and then us as is where the
crime is i went on the strip the other
day it smelled like everybody smoked
marijuana it just felt so dangerous i
thought i might need to get a ccw if i'm
getting gas and some of these goofy
people are coming out the strip and i
need to protect my family so that's why
i was going to ccw
thank you mr lee and to clarify you
mentioned you spoke privately with the
instructor but again to clarify 15
seconds did you find that offensive yeah
i did and that's why i went up it's like
when people take a picture with me and
they have a beer in their hand it puts
me in a position i don't want to be in
that gentleman heard for me but he
didn't have to hear me tell you how bad
he was i had already told him that i'm
not in for destroying people who are
running businesses i want to make sure
they're successful but they learn they
need to stop doing if they want to be
successful thank you denise has the next
question